[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
today i'm going to be discussing and
breaking down the differences between
the fateful jewel between voldemort and
dumbledore inside the ministry atrium
this jewel happened in the order of the
phoenix and it's arguably the most
impressive looking jewel on screen that
we've seen to date
it was a jewel of epic proportions
good against evil
light against dark and it totally
overshadowed all the boring stalemates
that harry had with voldemort however
one thing that is completely worth
mentioning is that their jewel was
represented very differently from book
to film the film adaptation certainly
took some liberties with the contents of
the book and
rather than staying true to the picture
that the book had initially painted for
us
it mixed things up
most likely for increased cinematic and
dramatic effect
but in doing so they actually portrayed
the characters in a very different light
than we had expected
and it was honestly quite inconsistent
with what we had initially read in the
books
if you only saw the film you might be
wondering
why couldn't voldemort end dumbledore
right then and there in the book their
skirmish of course breaks out when a
helpless harry who is in mortal danger
is saved by dumbledore who arrives just
in the nick of time i have nothing more
to say to you potter he voldemort said
quietly you have irked me too often for
too long
avada kedavra
harry had not even opened his mouth to
resist his mind was blank his wand
pointing uselessly at the floor but the
headless golden statue of the wizard in
the fountain had sprung alive
leaping from its plinth to land with the
crash on the floor between harry and
voldemort the spell merely glanced off
its chest as the statue flung out its
arms to protect harry what cried
voldemort staring around
and then he breathed dumbledore
voldemort raised his wand and another
jet of green light streaked at
dumbledore who turned and was gone in a
whirling of his cloak
next second he had reappeared behind
voldemort and waved his wand towards the
remnants of the fountain
the other statues sprang to life the
statue of the witch ran at bellatrix who
screamed and sent spells streaming
uselessly off its chest before it dived
at her pinning her to the floor
meanwhile the goblin and the house elf
scuttled towards the fireplaces set
along the wall and the one arm centaur
galloped at voldemort who vanished and
reappeared beside the pool the headless
statue thrust harry backwards away from
the fight as dumbledore advanced on
voldemort and the golden centaur
cantered around them both
in the film however this part is
completely taken out
dumbledore simply shows up using the flu
network and walks toward voldemort he
then says to voldemort it was foolish to
come here tonight tom
the auras are on their way
by which time i shall be gone and you
will be dead voldemort responds and
those lines are actually consistent from
book to film
these are also the lines that indicate
the proper beginning to their jewel
each man immensely confident that they
will be the one to overpower the other
back to the book
dumbledore flicked his own wand the
force of the spell that emanated from it
was such that harry though shielded by
his golden guard felt his hair stand on
end as it passed and this time voldemort
was forced to conjure a shining silver
shield out of thin air to deflect it
the spell whatever it was caused no
visible damage to the shield
though a deep gong-like note
reverberated from it an oddly chilling
sound
you do not seek to kill me dumbledore
called voldemort his scarlet eyes
narrowed over the top of the shield
above such brutality are you we both
know that there are other ways of
destroying a man tom
dumbledore said calmly continuing to
walk towards voldemort as though he had
not a fear in the world
as though nothing had happened to
interrupt his stroll up the hall
merely taking your life would not
satisfy me i admit
there is nothing worse than death
dumbledore snarled voldemort
indeed your failure to understand that
there are things much worse than death
has always been your greatest weakness
in the film however dumbledore and
voldemort instantly enter into a magical
power struggle
with one flick of their ones
dumbledore's red jet of light met
voldemort's green jet in mid-air and the
two were held their ground as sparks
flew and the room began to fall to
pieces
unable to contain the sheer magical
power being produced the pair appear to
be completely evenly matched there isn't
much talking like in the book and i
think that this is a particularly
important piece that they left out as i
think that their discussion reveals to
us just how powerful dumbledore truly is
throughout their jewel the books
continually describe dumbledore's
nonchalant attitude toward everything
going on
here he is faced head to head with one
of the darkest and most powerful wizards
of all time
but he's so calm
there are a few lines from the above
passage that suggest to me that
dumbledore is not even remotely worried
about losing
when he walks toward voldemort it's
constantly reinforced that he's calm and
that he had not a fear in the world
dumbledore's demeanor toward voldemort
during their jewel was even described as
though they were discussing the mata
over drinks i think that one of the
reasons that the films left this out was
because one-sided battles aren't fun
dumbledore at least as far as the books
are concerned is by far the most
powerful wizard of all time
not only was he magically talented but
he also possessed the elder wand during
their jewel if we are to go by strictly
the books voldemort was completely
outmatched however this wouldn't have
been as visually interesting on screen
and showing voldemort in such a
vulnerable state really takes away from
his character he's supposed to be this
dark presence the dark lord a
fear-inspiring figure that no one is
safe from
but that doesn't work when one of the
main characters on the protagonist's
side walks toward him like he's having a
picnic
so in that respect i sort of understand
why they omitted that portion of the
text from this scene
however i'm not sure that they should
have eliminated the dialogue completely
which they did
back to the book
another jet of green light flew from
behind the silver shield
this time it was the one armed centaur
galloping in front of dumbledore that
took the blast and shattered into a
hundred pieces
but before the fragment had even hit the
floor dumbledore had drawn back his wand
and waved it as though brandishing a
whip
a long thin flame flew from the tip
it wrapped itself around voldemort
shield and all
for a moment it seemed dumbledore had
won
but then the fiery rope became a serpent
which relinquished his hold on voldemort
at once and turned hissing furiously to
face dumbledore
once again this massively differs from
what we saw in the film
first of all there were no statues being
manipulated in the film version of their
jewel
not in any way shape or form
next dumbledore never seems to use any
sort of fiery whip like spell on
voldemort
the only part of this that does match
the film is the fiery serpent which does
attack dumbledore and was voldemort's
doing look out harry yelled but even as
he shouted another jet of green light
flew at dumbledore from voldemort's wand
and the snake struck
forks swooped down in front of
dumbledore opened his beak wide and
swallowed the jet of green light hole
he burst into flame and fell to the
floor
small wrinkled and flightless
at the same moment dumbledore brandished
his wand in one long fluid movement
the snake which had been an instant from
sinking its fangs into him
flew high into the air and vanished in a
wisp of dark smoke and the water in the
pool rose up and covered voldemort like
a cocoon of molten glass
this part is particularly interesting
because it actually seems to paint
dumbledore in a little bit more of a
vulnerable state
and i think that it suggests that
dumbledore was perhaps too confident at
the beginning of the duel in the film
adaptation at no point does dumbledore
need forks to show up and save him from
one of voldemort's attacks
but what the text shows us is that had
forks not been there dumbledore would
have either been hit with the vada
kadavra or the fiery snake spell
as both were being directed at him at
once
i feel that this is of particular
importance as it may even indicate that
dumbledore was the loser of their jewel
fawkes blocked a spell from hitting him
and unless dumbledore really didn't need
forks to do that it suggests that he may
have been the loser it's curious that
the film adaptation would have left this
out but once again i think that they may
have intentionally showcased voldemort
and dumbledore on fairly equal ground
after this happens the end of the jewel
in both the book and film is fairly
anticlimactic
in the book for a few seconds voldemort
was visible only as a dark rippling
faceless figure
shimmering and indistinct upon the
plinth
clearly struggling to throw off the
suffocating mass
then he was gone and the water fell with
the crash back into its pool
slopping wildly over the sides drenching
the polished floor
and in the film after dumbledore defends
against voldemort's barrage of glass
being flung toward him voldemort simply
disappears and possesses harry
so as we can see this jewel is massively
different from book to film and i feel
that the major differences can be summed
up as follows number one dialogue there
is a distinct lack of dialogue in the
film adaptation of their jewel
and it deprives the viewer of the sense
of confidence that dumbledore felt when
entering 2. avada kadavra and the
statues
in the books dumbledore is blocking
voldemort's constant barrage of killing
curse attacks by using statues however
in the film adaptation dumbledore seems
to be defending against voldemort's
killing curse with his own jet of red
light which contradicts everything that
we know about the spell
the killing curse is supposedly
unblockable
and harry can only defend against it
using expelliarmus because of special
circumstances
so the fact that dumbledore is simply
using whatever magic he wants to defend
against it doesn't actually make a lot
of sense
3. dumbledore being saved as we saw
above dumbledore ends up being saved by
forks in the book
this doesn't happen at all in the film
and it's interesting that they'd leave
this out as it may have actually meant
that dumbledore was the loser that is if
he needed forks to bail him out maybe he
didn't
4. dumbledore's demeanor in the film
dumbledore is sort of painted as a bit
weak frail and old when entering into
the jewel
this couldn't be further from the truth
as we can clearly see in the dialogue
from the text that dumbledore was very
strong and confident
so why couldn't voldemort kill
dumbledore the truth is whether you go
by the book or by the film dumbledore
was still far too powerful to be an easy
target to voldemort however if voldemort
had been the one in the possession of
the elder wand at the time
then things may have just ended up
differently and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember
it takes a great deal of bravery to
stand up to our enemies
but just as much to stand up to our
friends
you